[Musik]
[Applaus]
gazprom betrieb von nord stream zwei
extreme nicht garantieren russische
staat sucht freiwillige für ukraine
krieg und wirtschaftsminister robert
habeck löst debatte über gas verteilung
aus wer hat vorne im krisenfall und
damit herzlich willkommen zu 408 meine
gäste heute abend sind professor doktor
fritz fahren heute chemiker aber
umweltsenator in hamburg und buchautor
seine teesorte abend redet mit putin
sonst gehen die lichter aus auch mit von
der partie worüber ich mich sehr freue
in affing monaten bild viel zu bronze er
war einer der ersten reporter vor ort
und berichtete knapp fünf monate lang
aus dem krieg in der ukraine als
einziger deutscher journalist hat der
präsident sei mehrfach zum interview
getroffen sein appell schickt jetzt mehr
waffen in die ukraine alexander kissler
auch kann man schon ein stammgast bei
villach bezeichnet er ist politik
redakteur bei den neuen züricher zeitung
und ging beschäftigt der deutsche will
seine these heute abend deutschland
vermüllt ich bin gespannt bei mir liegt
nicht so viel müll last but not least
fdp politiker sind was hier in scheuer
er möchte den sehenswürdigkeiten das
licht ausknipsen und sagt schluss mit
der stromverschwendung schön dass sie
alle da sind und mein name ist nina
schenk ich freue mich ihnen gastgeberin
sein zu dürfen und versprechen ihnen
dass sie sich den nächsten 55 minuten
keinesfalls langweilen werden meine
these heute abend ist der russische
staatshaushalt erzielt trotz sanktionen
deutliches plus ist nicht nur eine these
sondern eine feststellung ich wünschte
mir diese nachricht käme von einer
russischen propaganda seite doch die
quelle ist der deutschlandfunk wo ist
dann halt nach offiziellen angaben im
ersten halbjahr trotz krieg und
sanktionen ein haushaltsüberschuss von
mehr als 20 milliarden euro erzielt es
ist eine bittere wahrheit die wehtut
aber die auch viele sanktions gegner
früh vorausgesagt haben hintergrund ist
der gestiegene ölpreis von dem russland
profitiert die westlichen sanktionen
haben bislang vor allem den import
westlicher waren nach russland erschwert
es gibt ökonomen die sagen dass die
sanktionen einfach länger zeit brauchen
sie brauchen noch etwas um die wirkung
zu erzielen aber wie lange soll
deutschland das noch durchhalten während
länder wie beispielsweise china oder
auch indien fröhlich weiter geschäfte
mit russland machen es ist möglich dass
wir mit den sanktionen vor allem uns
selbst schwächen erfahren heute wie ist
denn ihre zwischenbilanz nach 138 tagen
nun bei den sanktionen muss man
natürlich unterscheiden wir haben ja
eine reihe von sanktionen
eine haben wir eben nicht und das ist
der gasimport nach europa der ist nicht
sanktioniert und trotzdem müssen wir
damit rechnen dass uns der gas zu strom
abgestellt wird im augenblick glaube ich
sehen die chancen nicht so schlecht aus
er habe persönlich für das gut hat in
kanada interveniert und hat gesagt wir
brauchen die verdichterstation die soll
ich liefert werden damit wieder gas
fließen kann wenn es dazu nicht kommt
und
das weiß man natürlich nicht so lenski
hat ja protestiert und hat bei der
kanadischen regierung protest eingelegt
dann wird es dazu kommen dass wir nicht
nur ein problem des heizens haben dann
haben wir ein problem mit unserer
gesamten volkswirtschaft sie denn sagen
dass die sanktionen bislang gewirkt
haben sie verhängt wurden ich glaube
schon ich meine dass der druck ist ja
enorm und beim gas haben wir eben eine
ein ergebnis von 10 jähriger falscher
energiepolitik wir haben uns leider in
eine abhängigkeit begeben weil wir
erstens die kernenergie abgestellt haben
zweitens die kohle aber worin sehen sie
dass die sanktion wird wenn ich mir die
zahlen jetzt hier angucke und auch nur
die meldung in deutschland von
russischer staatshaushalt erzielt trotz
sanktionen deutliches plus da muss man
entweder sagen sind die zahlen aus dem
russischen finanzministerium falsch oder
man muss sagen die sanktionen haben
nicht gewirkt oder sind ja dich nur das
ist ja nicht nur der staatshaushalt
sondern ich glaube schon dass die
russischen bürger merken dass sie viele
produkte nicht mehr bekommen dass die
westlichen die westlichen importe fehlen
und dass auch produkte in russland
fehlen weil chips import gibt es auch
nicht mehr aber für uns ist doch jetzt
wirklich allerhöchste zeit man mit
einigen tabus aufzuräumen
das wird ihn so leid einem das tut wir
müssen da durch ohne dieses gas werden
wir wird dieses land zerstört und dann
werden wir auch nicht in der lage sein
ukraine irgendwelche hilfen
weiterzugeben sondern am ende muss es
wird wird es so sein dass wir das gar
nicht mehr bezahlen können denn wir
reden über 50
haben die sein sohn jetzt was gebracht
oder nicht herr kessler wie sehen sie
das na ja sie haben sicherheit nicht so
viel gebracht wenn man sich so am anfang
versprochen hat und wird es auch
verkündet worden also ich habe heute
noch im ohr v annalena baerbock unsere
außenministerin sagt diese sanktionen
werden russland in den ruin treiben also
russland werden ruiniert das wird
überhaupt ausfallen als welt politischer
ökonomischer player davon kann überhaupt
nicht die rede sein wir lesen sie zum
beispiel putzige geschichten dass also
der versuch mit dollars zu kopieren
offenbar gescheitert sei es gibt also
schmeckt und punkt und die
internetseiten sind voll von russischen
nutzern dieser nachgemacht der
amerikanische produkte sagen wir sind
schlecht da sei was vergammeln der salat
sei furchtbar
leider nicht kaputt damen wird russland
nicht kaputt gehen auch von weniger
champagner und weniger seife wird man
nicht kaputt gehen also man hat halt
einfach von deutscher seite den mund zu
voll genommen ich bin überhaupt kein
gegner der sanktionen natürlich muss man
allem was vernünftig ist russland
entgegensetzen allem was vernünftig sind
die sanktionen noch von dem ich glaube
wir sind jetzt so langsam an einen punkt
wo wir überlegen müssen ob das ausmaß
der sanktionen wirklich zu einer wende
des krieges von dem wir uns alle hoffen
dass sie zugunsten der ukraine ausfällt
beitragen wird ich würde sagen dazu
tragen eher waffenlieferungen bei als
diese sanktion es ist doch ganz klar wir
reden immer von der globalisierung die
globalisierung im osten unserer
erdhalbkugel funktioniert ja doch also
russland kann mit china handeltreiben
mit indien wir wissen dass die mehrzahl
der bevölkerung der welt an der sanktion
überhaupt nicht beteiligt ist das heißt
man hat den mund ich muss wiederholen zu
voll genommen man wird allein mit
sanktionen den krieg nicht zu gunst der
ukraine beenden können deswegen plädiere
ich eben dafür stärker was man schon
hätte früher machen sollen auf eine
militärische unterstützung zu setzen
jetzt da er wie blicken sie auf die
sanktion der ampel regierung hat die
ampeln guten job gemacht ja ich glaube
dass es völlig richtig ist hier scharfe
sanktionen auszusprechen und ich will
noch mal sagen wir sitzen hier
behütet in einem durchaus gut
klimatisierten studio und reden über die
frage eines angriffskrieges eines
barbarischen angriffskrieges und ich
würde das gerne auch mal ins verhältnis
setzen ab morgen gerade eine junge
familie hier in berlin getroffen die
seit wochen privat untergebracht war und
jetzt den schritt in die eigenen vier
wände geht als ich mit der mutter 44
gesprochen habe erzählte sie wirklich
erschreckend unter tränen was sie alles
in kiew verloren hat nämlich alles und
das will ich noch mal deutlich machen
dass es deshalb wichtig ist dass wir auf
der einen seite auch wenn es zu unseren
eigenen lasten geht so hart das ist
sanktionen rechtfertigen
können sie mir sagen ob erfolg erzielt
wurde nein wir sehen ja dass wir eine
instabilität bekommen wir haben wir
gerade über die frage der wechselkurse
gesprochen die sie kurz an getippt haben
in der frage was wird da eigentlich in
russland in den medien diskutiert sie
sagen dass der rubel stabil ist das
hängt mit den dividenden zusammen was
die wechselkurse betrifft dass wir
solche nachrichten bekommen also wer
genau hinschaut und sich auch das bibb
anschaut der wird sehen dass durchaus
die sanktionen eine wirkung haben und es
völlig richtig dass sanktionen immer
wieder hinterfragt werden und das tut
auch die bundesregierung im vergleich
zum euro hat sich der rubel jetzt nicht
dass man sagen kann deutlich schlechter
entwickelt damit ja ich meine damit dass
wenn man sich das insgesamt anschaut
durchaus festhalten muss dass das land
ja keine größere stabilität durch die
sanktionen gewonnen hat
so rissen auch die instabilität wir
genau erreichen denen eine größere stadt
richtig aber ihre die these bei ihnen
ist eine gegenthese sie sagen ja die
sanktionen führen nicht dazu dass es
eine instabile treten es gibt sondern
sie machen sogar den punkt drauf und
sagen sie haben eher den eindruck dass
das land stabiler ist als der euroraum
mit dem euro ich habe gesagt ihre these
ist sie gesagt haben yahoo wäre
geschwächt und da habe ich gesagt nein
der euro wurde auch geschwächt
in relation zueinander sid ich kann
wirklich nicht erkennen es konnte noch
kein politiker in der runde bislang
erklären wo die sanktionen jetzt
wirklich gewirkt haben also dass sie
wirklich hundertprozentig gewirkt haben
das konnten sie mir auch nicht erklären
gerade
nun sitze ich nicht im
verteidigungsausschuss bin ich mitglied
des deutschen bundestages ich kann ihnen
sagen was wir intern diskutieren auf der
ebene auch der
fraktionsvorsitzendenkonferenz um
austausch der bund länder weil wir
natürlich jeden tag auch mit den fragen
der bürgerinnen und bürger zu recht
konfrontiert sind was tut ihr da und was
hat das für auswirkungen auf unser leben
hier vor ort wir sehen es jetzt bei den
steigenden energiepreisen wir sehen dass
bei den lebenshaltungskosten
wir sehen das ja in dem alltäglichen
jedes einzelnen hier im inland und von
daher müssen wir uns jeden tag diese
frage auch stellen lassen was diese
sanktionen bringen wie sehr kann man an
den zahlen glauben weil das ist
natürlich schon eine wichtige frage wie
weit kann man sich darauf verlassen dass
jetzt heute beispielsweise der
deutschlandfunk gemeldet hat na ja ich
glaube schon dass man sich auf die
zahlen verlassen kann und man kann ja
sehen wo der rubel steht man kann sehen
wie sich die wirtschaft entwickelt das
sind zahlen die realistisch sind ich
glaube es ist ganz einfach so lange es
keine öl- und gas-embargo es gibt wird
russland weiterhin so gut dastehen oder
schlecht dastehen wie es momentan der
fall ist und da kann man natürlich die
position vertreten und sagen wir können
nicht ohne russisches gas wir können
nicht ohne öl aber das bedeutet dann
auch gleichzeitig eben dass russland
nicht so sehr darunter leiden wird ich
glaube dennoch dass man mittelfristig
sicherlich dort ergebnisse sehen wird
insbesondere im hochtechnologiebereich
also all das weißt du vielleicht ist den
kunden beide sagen das braucht einfach
länger das keines ist braucht definitiv
längere zeit aber man muss ja davon
ausgehen auf was der künstler gesagt hat
die deutsche regierung hat es so
verkauft als würde es jetzt passieren
und russland würde jetzt geschwächt und
das ist ja auch das was man eigentlich
bräuchte ja das ziel war ja russland zu
schwächen druck auszuüben dass der krieg
in der ukraine beendet wird
das ist nicht der fall das ist definitiv
so das ist das problem ich glaube
dennoch nicht dass das dazu führen zu
sagen ja dann war das falsch wir nehmen
jetzt mal sanktionen zurück ja ich halte
auch das argument andere machen
geschäfte mit russland
für kein argument was uns interessieren
sollten nicht weil ich finde schon dass
wir als deutschland natürlich eine auch
einen moralischen kompass haben müssen
wir einen kleinen romanischen company
also ich glaube dass china einen anderen
moralischen kompass hat als deutschland
ich meine die spanier die im augenblick
lustig gas aus russland erhöhen 25
prozent der spanier den spanischen gases
kommt jetzt aus russland bei uns geht's
runter bei der geht es rauf und polen
hat sich über nord stream 1 eingedeckt
hat ihre lager voll unsere lager sind
nicht voll aber sie haben ja schon immer
über die das drama der deutschen
energiepolitik gesprochen das war die
spd die uns dorthin gebracht wie sie
merkel mitte ist mit mit der mit der spd
ich glaube das ist schon viel früher
angefangen hat auch vor frau merkel und
auch npd teilweise wird ja absolut
einmal jetzt sind wir eben da wo wir
sind von daher halte ich sozusagen zu
sagen okay
müssen sich mal vorstellen der krieg ist
138 tage alt und wie deutschen fangen
jetzt an schon zu sagen ach das hilft ja
alles nichts und das ist schlecht und
die sanktionen und jetzt wollen wir aber
nicht mehr uns geht ist wahnsinnig gut
ja muss das noch mal aufgerafft ich
möchte wie gesagt schon vor tagen aus
der ukraine zurückgekehrt in dombach es
ist dramatisch weiterhin verliert die
ukraine da
territorium aber identischen sterben ja
dann kennen wir aber ja ein bisschen
wieder in die krone schleife hauptsache
wir machen was und ob die wirkung jetzt
da ist oder nicht ist egal also müssen
die sanktionen nicht wirklich
zielgerichtet sein um auch schaden vom
deutschen volk abzuwenden
nochmal also entweder macht man öl und
gas sanktionen oder es wird so
weitergehen da kann man jetzt noch
zielgerichteter reingehen und man kann
ja die position vertreten und sagen
deutschland braucht russisches gas und
öl okay ich glaube man sollte
drastischer sein das ist meine
persönliche meinung allerdings wenn man
jetzt sagt okay wir sagen zu nennen hier
noch ein bisschen da noch ein bisschen
ich glaube man müsste noch viel härter
auf personenbezogene sanktionen
unbedingt ich glaube so zu sagen man
muss die oligarchischen töchter und
familie noch viel breiter treffen weil
ich glaube schon
dass das dazu führt dass dieser moment
mal also jetzt gar nicht mehr in westen
urlaub machen das will ich also ich
glaube man da kann man sicherlich noch
was tun aber generell ist die große
frage was ist mit öl und gas ja da muss
ich ihn wirklich widersprechen ich
glaube sie wissen nicht was sie wirklich
reden weil
hamburg ort wie sie wissen da sind aber
die deutschen fast alleine da alle
anderen sagen wir brauchen das noch das
pipeline höhe aber wir haben gesagt okay
wir steigen aus beim gas ist das
natürlich völlig anders aber ich sage
ich mal so lange ukraine russisches gas
nimmt und an dem durch geleiteten
russischen gas geld verdient sollte mir
niemand kommen mit einer moralischen
position dass wir doch bitteschön als
erste uns von der klippe zu stürzen
haben sie wissen nicht worüber sie reden
wir reden über 6 millionen arbeitsplätze
sie werden hier einen zusammenbruch
deutschland bekommen das fängt beim
brötchen becker an und das hört bei den
düngemitteln auf das hört bei der chemie
fängt es an und bei der stahlindustrie
dass auch sie haben flächendeckend
arbeitsplatzverlust und glauben sie im
ernst sie werden die deutschen dazu
kriegen noch weiter ukraine was ich
gerne mache unterstützen wenn wir selber
indem eine sanktion machen die aber das
macht er da bereits im herbst als wenn
wenn putin jetzt die glasplatten abstand
passiert ja genau das dann und sagen ja
wir so ein dass moment moment also
sollen wir jetzt darauf warten und
weiter in putins hände begeben und sagen
okay wir
sind ihm völlig ausgeliefert und warten
jetzt mal ab und gott das wären
vielleicht tut er dies oder vielleicht
tut er jene ist dann wir sollten dem
keinen vorhalt leisten denn in meinen
die das wirklich nicht die diese
verdichterstation geliefert haben hat
ihm natürlich eine gute ausrede gegeben
um zu sagen ich zeige ich mal wo der
bartl den most holt und deswegen muss
man ja und so habe ich heute gast
verstanden sie haben nur die ersten den
ersten satz zitiert die haben gesagt wir
können das nicht garantieren wir haben
bis heute noch keine bestätigung dass
diese verdichterstation rechtzeitig
kommt und die musik
der stillstand wenn der stillstand
zehn tage dauert und die die
verdichterstation kommt dann hat der
kreml übrigens erklärt dann wird er auch
wieder gas liefert moment weiß nur sage
aufmaße der kreml erklärt glauben sie
ernsthaft dass was putin heute sagt wird
auch morgen der fall sein hat uns vor
dem krieg gesagt er kriegt wird es nicht
gehen haben sie die relative sie sagen
ich stelle mal von von vor mirós ab dann
sind sie doch ein selbstmörder wollen
sie das ganze volk in unglück bringen
wir müssen noch alles tun dass putin uns
nicht hier sozusagen ins verderben
bringen und wenn wir ihn beim wort
nehmen
es bricht ja da haben wir eine situation
die umwelt doch das ist in der kreml
erzählt und auch daran zweifel daran
dass sie ein problem verkennen auch
russland hat ein interesse gas so
liefert nicht aus geldlichen gründen da
da gibt es erdgasquellen die konnte ich
nicht so einfach abstellen hat sie
können sie natürlich abstellen indem sie
sozusagen das erdgas verbrennen ja mit
dem klima sehr viel helfen und deswegen
haben sie natürlich interesse und
gewisses maß auch zulief aber es geht ja
kurzfristig auch noch druck den russland
weiter ausüben will auf die ukraine auf
europas geht um spaltung es geht darum
sondern habt ihr eigentlich war auch mal
auch erlassen so dass die ukraine am
anfang wird dem gast also ganz kurz das
ist doch das was gerade passiert die
debatten den sag ich mal seit ungefähr
zehn tagen geführt werden in deutschland
und europa das ist genau das was putin
erreichen will er will dass wir angst
haben dass wir dass wir nervös werden
dass wir sagen was passiert jetzt dass
wir nicht mehr darüber sprechen wie
viele menschen in der ukraine sterben
dass wir nicht mehr darüber sprechen
welche kriegsverbrechen putin begeht
sondern dass wir uns gegenseitig
kritisieren für die frage was die
energieversorgung bleiben wir einmal bei
der frage kann man mit putin verhandeln
herz ja ja ich finde das bezeichnen
gestatten sie mir die anmerkung dass sie
sind auch eine ganze zeit lang
umweltsenator gewesen für die spd glaube
ich in hamburg wenn ich das richtig in
erinnerung habe mein eindruck war dass
die spd mittlerweile auch aus diesem
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine ihr
verhältnis zu russland durchaus
hinterfragt hat ich mache mal ein
fragezeichen bei ihnen da dran im
ausblick das dürfen sie nicht als frage
zahlen ich habe hier genauso große
kritik an putin geht der andere ich sehe
nur und habe reagiert auf die frage
wollen wir selber abstellen und herz hat
das müssen sie beantworten wollen wir
selber abstellen ich will mit ihnen die
fragen müssen beantwortet
nur darum geht es ich will mit ihnen
eine diskussion nach vorne führen der
professor vahrenholt weil die frage ist
doch was können wir tun wenn wir erster
anzeichen sie haben wir zu recht darauf
hingewiesen schauen wir mal einfach in
unserem land schauen wir was die basf
meldet was wir von juniper hören was
können wir tun um unsere eigene
volkswirtschaft zu stabilisieren und sie
nicht zu schaden wenn wir genau wissen
dass die energiepolitik der letzten
jahrzehnte zahlreiche regierung unter
der führung maßgeblich von von union und
spd dazu beigetragen haben dass wir eine
einseitige energiepolitik machen und
dann habe ich ausstieg hat die fdp
beschlossen dann müssen wir sind aber
jetzt die einzelnen die deutlich sagen
soll dann verlängere steht die familie
an der seite so unterstütze ich sie
haben wir bitten bundes haben sich
gesagt haben sich enthalten wir haben ja
kann ich ihnen sagen weil wir keine
abgestimmte position im ampelbündnis
haben und die schaufenster anträge von
friedrich merz die wenn man nicht immer
leicht sagen muss sagen wir arbeiten
alle dieser abgestimmt
lassen auch nicht nach in der debatte um
das deutlich zu nach der sommerpause so
spät sein aber die fdp diese chance
verpasst das muss man ganz klar gesagt
ihnen wir bleiben da sehr ernsthaft
daran weil es für uns wichtig ist immer
noch mal die frage ist wie können wir in
diesem land dazu beitragen das was an
versäumnissen passiert ist das was wir
an der herausforderung sehen
volkswirtschaftlich abzufedern darüber
würde ich gerne schmidt gerne weil wir
können uns nicht in die abhängigkeit
begeben dadurch nicht bei uns haben wir
müssen raus und deswegen schon längst
eine abhängigkeit wir begeben uns da
gebe ich an scharia recht wir müssen
raus und deswegen ist die frage warum
fördern wir nicht eigenes erdgas wir
haben 23 billionen aber die und die
bundesregierung will es nicht fördern
sie will nicht ran weil sie sagt er da
müssen wir dann ja das gesetz aufheben
das fracking in deutschland verbietet
aber wir nehmen gerne fracking gas aus
den usa das gleiche ist die kernkraft
haben wir diskutiert
und das gleiche ist mit kohlekraftwerken
wir können natürlich auch mehr
kohlekraftwerke wieder aktivieren da
fehlt es mir an der ernsthaftigkeit
dieses thema wirklich anzupacken
und am ende kann man nur hoffen dass wir
dieses ufer erreichen denn wir müssen
weg von putin das ist völlig klar dass
aber das hilft uns nicht entschuldigen
wenn ich das sage dass wir da irgendwie
mal ein paar beleuchtung am
brandenburger tor zudem geht das hilft
nun wirklich überhaupt nichts das sind 0
0 0 0 0 0 1 gleich aus dem heute mal ein
bisschen mehr redezeit verschaffen das
war mein todo heute was ich mir selbst
bin ich dafür bekannt geben wenig zu
reden ein bisschen irgendwer selbst rein
gehen also und die lage na ja die frage
ist ja was tun wir jetzt und wie wer ist
verantwortlich für die lage in die wir
uns gekommen sind weil politisch und
tier auf nationaler ebene was wir jetzt
tun da würde ich meinem rednern zur
linken anfahren zustimmen wir müssen
natürlich auch diskussionen führen über
fracking über atomkraft kernkraft ist
doch völlig klar und dass gerade der
sich momentan das lorbeerkranz es kaum
erwehren können de robert habeck ja eben
nicht bereit ist über diesen schatten zu
springen an diesem dogma festhält als
wird es also als blasphemischen verstoß
gegen die die zehn gebote der grünen
aufgefasst werden das verstehe ich
überhaupt nicht also ist weiß gott nicht
so pragmatisch wie erscheint und wir von
beiden teilen der presse gemacht wird
herbig sie haben wir auch noch eine sehr
sehr große to do liste das andere ist
natürlich eine steile lernkurve liegt
vor ihnen her habe ich freundlich zu
formulieren
das andere ist natürlich wie gehen wir
mit russland und wir blicken wir auf
russland sie haben vorhin das wort
gefragt von den interessen also auch
russland habe ein interesse auch putin
habe ein interesse da bin ich
mittlerweile skeptisch dass wir das so
in der debatte als ernsthaftes stiftende
handlungsleitend kategorie einbringen
können ich erinnere mich an diskussionen
zwei drei vier fünf tage vor dem
überfall russlands auf die ukraine habe
ich teilgenommen also als zuschauer da
hieß es ja nie wird der ukraine
überfallen es gab einen großen vortrag
eines sohns geschäften spiele
theoretikers hat gesagt dass sich
dagegen das spricht dagegen dass alles
spricht dagegen eher müsste komplett
verrückt sein 24 stunden später war das
verrückte in anführungszeichen wahr
geworden also ich frage mich inwieweit
können wir im umgang mit einem menschen
der bereit ist tode in millionenhöhe im
eigenen und fremden land zu riskieren zu
erwarten dass er für rationale argumente
zugänglich ist und dass er auf rationale
weise eine interessengeleitete politik
für sein eigenes land macht da habe ich
meine großen zweifel dran deshalb glaube
ich vor dieser kategorie also wir müssen
schauen dass wir herrn putin keinen
vorhalt geben zu tun wir dürfen nicht
reizen wir müssen seine restliche da
aber interessen haben sie gesagt und
keine vorhanden interessen oder seegras
zulieferer handel hatte sie momentan das
interesse der ukraine zu gewinnen er hat
eine andere game changer zwei zu führen
alles was dort gesagt hat diese
hässlichen reden wo von wanzen
gesprochen wird die er ausräuchern will
von fliegender ausspucken will das sind
vielleicht die wahren interessen und
nicht die gaslieferung was ist für die
durch durch die regierung eine sache
wenn wir uns anschauen sozusagen wie die
ampel mit der ganzen ukraine thematik
umgegangen ist wir sind immer hinten
dran also egal was passiert bleibt
unklar
damit haben wir ein bisschen diskutieren
ja wie lange wollen sie denn noch
diskutieren also ich meine wenn es zu
spät ist dann hilft ihnen das auch nicht
mehr das gleiche bei der frage wie gehen
wir jetzt mit dem gas um da warten wir
auch darauf was macht jetzt putin um
gottes willen was tut der kreml auch da
haben wir in wahrheit keine strategie
also bei allen fragen man kann ja
unterschiedliche meinung
unterschiedliche positionen haben aber
ich würde mir von dieser regierung
endlich mal wünschen dass es einen
klaren plan gibt wo geht's hin robert
habe erzählt immer viel was alles nicht
möglich ist und wie schwierig das ist
und dann guckt ein bisschen in seinen
instagram und säuselt ein bisschen und
das war's dann und harry potter hat wohl
immer herr scholz hat in jedem zweiten
interview wir haben einen plan klammer
auf aber ich sage ihnen euch nicht das
finde ich indiskutabel hören
herbolzheimer hat heute im plan
mitgebracht hatte ja seine thesen zeige
eine forderung an die regierung meine
forderung an die regierung so ist es ich
sage auch nach dem was ich in den
letzten wochen in der ukraine gesehen
habe nämlich dass die westlichen waffen
endlich einen unterschied machen vor
acht wochen als sich eine aus der
ukraine war da haben mir die offiziere
dort gesagt wir können uns nicht
verteidigen gegen die russische art wie
wir haben einfach viel zu wenig
tatsächlich sieht man jetzt nicht
unbedingt die zwölf panzerhaubitzen aus
deutschland die auch aber das sind
natürlich führt zu weniger aber
us-waffen die einen großen unterschied
machen in den vergangenen tagen wir
sehen dass die frontlinie dort von den
ukrainern besser gehalten werden kann
ich glaube wir müssen jetzt unbedingt
mehr liefern denn die frontlinie ist
lang es sind fast 2000 kilometer es
braucht dringend weitere
es braucht dringend moderne waffen auf
der ganzen linie damit die ukraine sich
dort verteidigen kann denn immer noch
ist es so dass russland langsam aber
stetig voran kommt bestimmte dörfer dort
einnimmt und das bedeutet wenn wir
nichts tun dann ist der gesamte dorf
bald verloren jetzt sind wir noch zu
zurückhaltend mit den waffenlieferungen
aus deutschland
naja ich muss ihnen ehrlich sagen
solange der bundeskanzler nicht in der
lage ist mal in einer rede auch klar zu
formulieren was er möchte sondern nach
wie vor immer vom ringtausch spricht und
das als ein seine haut abgestimmt sagte
ja alles fein abgestimmt irgendwie vom
ringtausch spricht sind wir gefühlt weit
weg von dem was paul ronzheimer
anspricht und ich bin ich teile diese
position persönlich dass auch
erkenntlich geworden ist ich glaube mit
dem panzerhaubitzen war es jetzt
nachvollziehbar das modernere geräte
auch zu mehr territorialen gewinn führen
und wenn man sich allein anschaut wie
viele verletzte soldaten wir haben ich
glaube bis zu 7000 1500 die sterben dann
sind das situation wo wir dringend bei
der größe auch der armee die derzeit an
der frontlinie ist mit entsprechend
guten gerät
eine unterstützung leisten können und
müssen wir sind in der verein trage ich
für waffen zu liefern also jetzt mein
fdp politiker gesagt auf die frage was
sollen wir denn eigentlich liefern wir
haben nichts
sagen also was gehören wir dann
überhaupt liefern was haben wir denn ich
kenne die inventarliste nicht insoweit
kann ich ihnen nicht sagen was das was
im bestand ist ich kann ihnen nur sagen
die erste strategie war der sogenannte
ringtausch dass man sozusagen all das
was ihn verwendet werden kann aus alten
gerät in die ukraine geht dahinter
steckt ja nichts anderes und das ist ja
eine formulierung die der bundeskanzler
scholz bei jeder gelegenheit verwendet
windows geräte mit denen die ukraine
umgehen konnten genau ohne über die
verlage legen sprechen wie können wir
jetzt mit modernem gerät
vor ort für unterstützung sorgen und wir
wollen diese und stützung wir haben das
klar formuliert unsere
verteidigungspolitische sprecherin
und vorsitzender verteidigungsausschuss
hat das getan agnes strack zimmermann
sehr deutlich und das ist auch unsere
haltung auch gegenüber dem
bundeskanzleramt zu
stemmen ich stimme jeder voll
zufallstreffer meinert ihre
unterstützung aber es nutzt ja nichts
wenn wir eine
bundesverteidigungsministerium wie heißt
sie noch lamprecht glaube ich ja die
also dann immer nur erklärt was alles
nicht geht dass man es ja unglaublich
viel tut das nicht im einzelnen sagen
könne die sich also zu lächerlichen
figur macht wenn sie also im bundestag
versucht um gewisse panzer ist nicht
panzer zu erklären also rohre die
irgendwohin schießen und woanders
runterkommen das klingt als wäre die
frau auf dem rummelplatz und wird
erklären wie also eine schießbude
funktioniert und es geht hier wirklich
um den einsatz der bundeswehr tüchtigen
der bundeswehr und militärische hilfe
für ein land im unter überlebenskampf
also solange ich eine solche frau in
dieser situation mit dieser aufgabe
betrauen da ist mir das einfach nicht
wichtig genug da muss ich auf den hof an
die ampel machen anderen scholz an alle
so lange an der frau lamprecht als
spitze der ehemaligen hatte als das
bundesministerium festhält so lang ist
ein eigentlich das nicht so furchtbar
wichtig in welchem zustand die
bundeswehr sich befindet mit welcher
militärischen unterstützung zieht der
ukraine beim überleben helfen kann das
ist so eine theoretische diskussion und
ich meine alle parteien fdp cdu spd
grüne dazu beigetragen dass über zwölf
jahre lang die bundeswehr wirklich
völlig entmannt wo ja klar auch eine
schuld sagt er ist halt nicht ändern
dann setzt der fall am prado dabei er
ist ein großer held des rheder dunkel
wir können uns über personal im
tagesablauf uns dass wir die fakten
reden es ist nichts da was man sozusagen
verteilen könnte jetzt haben wir 100
millionen 100 milliarden programm ist
das umgesetzt wird das dauert jahre die
fehler der vergangenheit kann man eben
leider nicht so schnell korrigieren wie
wir auch die fehler in der
energiepolitik nicht innerhalb von
wenigen wochen quallen flachen wollen
ist wenn man die waffen liefern könnte
ja natürlich muss man auch sehen dass
auf der anderen seite haben wir jetzt
festgestellt ein irrationaler diktator
ist ja und das risiko hat mit sicherheit
olaf scholz jeden tag abzuwägen wie weit
habe ich schaden vom deutschen volk
abzuwenden das ist artikel 56 der
deutschen verfassung nicht er hat ja
nicht auf die ukrainische verfassung
seien eingeleitet sondern auf die
deutsche verfall und verantwortlich für
uns dass es uns nicht in den orkus reist
haben sie das gefühl dass manche
politiker in deutschland zu wenig gerade
am herzen liegt naja zumindest kann man
ja festhalten wir sind einen langen weg
schon gegangen
früher war es eine doktrin in
kriegsgebiete werden wir keine waffen
liefern mittlerweile tun wir das aus
guten gründen das kritisiere ich nicht
aber ich finde wir müssen auch
irgendwann mal sehen dass wir in einer
selbst geschaffenen zwangssituation sind
wir sind erpressbar geworden und das ist
nicht mit starken worten einfach vom
tisch zu fegen das ist so und da muss
man sich dann auch entsprechend so
verhalten dass man nicht sozusagen sein
eigenes volk in den untergrund was man
ja auch leute pressberger die
erpressbarkeit ist zum beispiel die
abstellung des gases das ist meine sie
müssen sich einfach mal vorstellen was
das bedeutet wenn sie eine pipeline
abstellen der vorsitzende des des
verband der chemischen industrie hat uns
das mal erklärt er hat gesagt das ist
ein wahn kessel zug von frankfurt bis
sie will ja nur für die chemische
industrie nicht für alle anderen nur für
die chemische industrie und dann müssen
sie mal raten für wie lange dieser
reicht das reicht für sechs tage damit
wir wissen über welche dimension wir
reden das ist nicht mit ein paar
schiefgehen war zu ersetzen das geht
leider nicht und es wird auch dann noch
schlimmer wenn man dann auch noch kämpfe
werden gerade bei der waffen diskussion
wer gerade über die angefragte welche
welche schwierigkeiten entstehen und
welche abwägungen müssen wir vornehmen
und die schiffchen für sie sind ist das
sind die lng terminals oder wichtig den
g 7 prozent bringt dass man genau da aus
dieser haltung müssen wir haben da
sitzen ja machen da jahren ist ja
jahrelang geschlafen wirklich doch dafür
nur wir müssen sehen das abstellen von
kernkraftwerken bringt mehr als 1 bei
der
genau und bei der frage der abwägung
nicht verstehe auch da verstehe ich den
deutschen kurs nicht man gibt ein
bisschen
aber nicht genügend um die ukraine
ukraine tatsächlich so zu unterstützen
dass sie tatsächlich territorium halten
kann und es ist nicht ganz richtig dass
wir alles liefern was wir können das
machen wir eben nicht da gibt es sehr
viele beispiele für es gibt auch das
beispiel von rheinmetall der also dass
man sozusagen mit der waffenproduktion
der ukraine helfen könnte also dass sie
selbst diese waffen dort erwerben all
das passiert nicht und da frage ich mich
warum glaubt olaf scholz macht das jetzt
ein unterschied wenn er sagt er schickt
12 panzerhaubitzen aber fiktiv gesagt
nicht 100 im moment ich will ja nur ich
sage ja fiktiv als beispiel dafür
dieser glaube dass wladimir putin dort
im kreml sitzt und irgendwie nach zählt
wie viele waffen wie es geschickt haben
und deswegen irgendwie wütender oder
noch wütender oder besonders und auf
deutschland ist den habe ich nie
verstanden und das war ja auch das was
olaf scholz gesagt hat er gibt so ein
bisschen das soll auch nicht auffallen
und dann sah redet man auch nicht
darüber weil dann könnte putin ja böse
werden ja also das verstehe ich
überhaupt nicht dass es das eine und das
zweite dieses argument was ja auch sehr
häufig kommt in der waffen diskussion ja
die waffen könnten daher getroffen
werden also alle waffen die ich dort an
der front gesehen habe deutsche warfen
us-waffen die wurden nicht getroffen
über das schienennetz werk in der
ukraine kommt dass dort sehr sicher rein
und das ist bewiesen worden also sollten
wir mehr tun wenn wir denn der
überzeugung sind und wenn wir denn
wollen dass die ukraine diesen krieg
gewinnt und wenn wir das nicht wollen
dann sollten wir im wort gewinn ist für
dich mit 1 0 gewinnen gewinnen ist für
mich großen an die grenze zu bringen
wieder na ja zumindest auf das gebiet
vor dem 23 februar so dass wir sehr
leichtgängig das will jetzt dorthin
nicht auch saarlands gewählt dass auch
darf ich das andere geht das was ein
mittelfristiges langfristiges ziel was
natürlich die ukraine hat alle täter
brachen teile das hat ja doch noch
angeboten nein das war nicht angeboten
grimm und don was war doch man hat doch
ist jedoch zurückgepfiffen worden er
doch in istanbul dieses thema mit
plattem und da muss es sinn mehr ich
glaube da kommen wir so eine sehr tiefe
diskussion da kambodscha dann gab es
keine
verantwortung kriegsverbrechen awi
gehört den großen kriegsverbrechen aber
noch einmal zurück zu der zu der waffen
frage ich glaube das ist wirklich eine
ganz entscheidende frage die wir uns
auch als deutsche stellen müssen wollen
wir dass die ukraine im stande ist dort
erfolgreich zu sein oder nicht wenn wir
das an ihre grenze wo flugzeuge liefern
sollen wir auch dort mal so verbotszone
machen dann sind wir kriegsparteien
wollen sich parteien sie worüber reden
sie ich habe nie eine flugverbotszone
gefordert ich war immer dagegen ich
finde dass wir zum beispiel durchaus
panzer liefern sollten marder panzer zum
beispiel das ist glaube ich dringend
notwendig aber ich habe ja diese frage
viel allgemeiner formuliert weil ich
glaube die ist sehr entscheidend wenn
wir das nicht voll und und nicht daran
glauben dass die ukraine diesen krieg
gewinnen kann dann müssen wir eine
andere strategie von als bundesregierung
aber dieses von allem ein bisschen und
nicht zu viel das funktioniert nicht
kaputt ihn sehr spannendes zitat von
frau berbalk gelesen im stern und zwar
vorüber kann man mit jemandem verhandeln
der nicht mal bereit ist mit dem
internationalen komitee vom roten kreuz
humanitäre korridore für die flüchtlinge
für die flucht von zivilisten zu
ermöglichen und das erfahren heute hat
mich zum beispiel schon auch zum
nachdenken angeregt wie weit können wir
wissen dass man mit putin verhandeln
bekanntlich angetrieben der guten
verteidigen mir geht es nur darum dass
er in der debatte an ich habe wirklich
ob kann interessen zu verteidigen ich
habe auch klar gesagt
von dem von den barbarischen krieg seien
aber die frage die ich hier bitte
berücksichtigt will der bundeskanzler
muss in dem ganzen konzert in der gesamt
politik der verantwortung die er hat
immer wissen dass er auch so zu sagen
wenn er eingreift wenn er sanktionen
macht das die nicht am ende dazu führen
dass wir schlechter dran sind mehr
getroffen werden als die die er treffen
will und mir verlangt wird jetzt auch
das schlusswort für einer kurzen
unterbrechung und gleich geht es weiter
mit dem brandenburger tor und müll
darauf finde ich schon sehr gespannt bis
gleich
[Musik]
also da kann ich dann ein lauter
brauchen und nicht ernst nehmen als
sogenannten experten
meine damen und herren bei 485 köpfen
sind meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
thema mitgebracht was ihn bewegt freut
oder studiert
[Musik]
so nicht über chat buschi jörges will
wetten seit august aber niemand von den
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
ja das wollen hier einfach nur freiheit
diese grün-roten der damen führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russen
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur der ard zu überlassen lasst
den leuten spaß wir sehen da etwas was
eigentlich fatale ist in der politik bei
den journalisten deren job ist es doch
gerade abweichende meinungen zu finden
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig
dufte
vielleicht einmal kurz
doch das sind übliche anorak träger
ausdrücken und ich hatte meinen bei
allem eine sache immer bekommt wer
kümmert sich darum niemand
will den mann bis er ganz knapp drüber
sprechen das ist einfach nicht fertig
richtig froh ist die aufgabe von
journalismus einfach die verlautbarungen
der politik zu hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und machen jetzt direkt
weiter mit herrschern
das was mich in diesen tagen umtreibt
ist dass wir als staat der staat selbst
immer wieder von den bürgerinnen und
bürgern in dieser schwierigen zeit
sparmaßnahmen verlangt jeder muss den
gürtel enger schnallen nur der stadt ist
nicht in der lage bei sich selbst
genauer hinzuschauen und deshalb haben
wir vorgeschlagen zu prüfen inwieweit
gerade ästhetische beleuchtung hier in
der hauptstadt
reduziert oder gar hand geschaltet
werden kann das kann sein die
reichstagskuppel nach 0 uhr im licht
zudem das rote rathaus in berlin
abzuschalten oder aber auch das
brandenburger tor in einer reduzierten
beleuchtung und damit dazu beizutragen
den ihn in denen dieser krise
unterstützung durch den staat brauchen
über ein energie hilfsfonds tatsächlich
hilfe zukommen zu lassen das was der
staat von uns bürgerinnen und bürgern
erwartet das muss ja auch bei sich
selbst leisten und hier ernsthaft prüfen
wie viel bringt da sie viel
stromersparnis trinken euro wenn ich
nicht mehr zehn euro solchen es ist ja
nicht so eben deswegen ist das eine
reine
eine reine veranstaltung für den
showroom ich bin dass er man kann das
machen wenn man sagen ich will ein
signal aussenden das ist in ordnung aber
wir sollten doch jetzt das nicht
überhöhen und sagen damit sparen wir
energie damit führen wir die bürger doch
hinter die fichte wir müssen ihnen doch
sagen wo die wirklichen probleme unserer
energiewirtschaft liegen doch nicht
daran dass wir ein bisschen licht haben
licht ist das geringste problem ja also
ich ich ich muss jetzt leider gottes
sagen hätte das klang ist für mich wie
kam das tut mir leid
sie haben angefangen der staat muss den
gürtel enger schnallt sich auch
wunderbar die zahl der parlamentarischen
staatssekretäre wird reduziert die hohe
zahl der beamten die gerade unter ampel
noch einmal aufgestockt werden sind ins
uferlose der bundestag wird jetzt
endlich mal kleiner die verwaltung wird
geringer die bürokratie wird abgebaut
vielleicht verdient sogar ein paar
minister mal weniger wir auch mal ein
zeichen aber gürtel enger schnallen des
staates stehen welten sänger starb wenig
weil ich gürtel enger schnallen des
staates soll darin bestehen dass der
staat das geld das ihm nicht gehört für
weniger strom aus gibt an öffentlichen
gebäuden das ist doch lächerlich habe
gesagt der staat erwartet und es ist ja
auch so besser versteht jeder jeder
prüft ja gerade selbst
sie können doch sich die landesregierung
anschauen den unterschiedlichsten
konstellationen sie könne sich die
bundesregierung in meinetwegen die ampel
regierung auf bundes sind lockere aber
eine andere landesregierung überall wir
jedoch gesehen doch sparen sie mich
erstmal den ein jahren beantworten
damaligen zweiten doch in der situation
dass jeder für sich prüft wo kann er
einsparen wie geht er quasi mit seinem
haushaltseinkommen um wo kann er
herrscht ein riesiger unter rein konz
ist unser steuergeld die fragen
einkommen wenn man ein energie
hilfsfonds wie beispielsweise hier in
berlin mit 380 millionen auf legt und
sagt wir wollen denjenigen die in dieser
harten krise es nicht schaffen können
aufgrund ihrer haushaltssituation die
das mehr an energiekosten zu zahlen auch
staatlich unter den armen greifen dann
kann man das mit einer weiteren
neuverschuldung tun was ich für falsch
halte ich auch für feiern oder man
überprüft staatlicherseits wo haben wir
ausgabe situationen und das ist zum
beispiel die ästhetische beleuchtung an
entscheidungen wissen die zahl bringe
ich ihn nächste woche mit wir rechnen
das wäre doch was ist ein ferrari hat
sagt 10.000 euro ich halte dagegen halte
selbst an dem sie nehmen die gesamte
öffentliche beleuchtung machen sozusagen
berlin insgesamt dicht und dass die
leute abend nicht mehr sicher ob die
berater gehen
natürlich unter drei millionen und den
vorschlag lehne ich ab
wir brauchen eine differenzierte debatte
über die frage was es
sicherheitsrelevant und was das
ästhetische beleuchtung und diese frage
die muss in diesen tagen doch wohl
zulässig sein darüber zu diskutieren
aber das ist keine person der stadt
besteht aus personen und wenn da ein
leuchtendes beispiel abgeben will
anführungszeichen ein leuchtendes
beispiel da müssen die
staatsbediensteten auch mal vorangehen
es gibt viele sogar habig beschwert sich
sogar auf einmal dass er zu viel geld
verdient wer hält ihn davon ab davon was
abzugeben wenn halten bundesrat sei ein
taktisch hat mehr steuern
wird
überzeugen aber wenn ich jetzt eine
fünfte beleuchtung ist am brandenburger
tor desto eher kann halten sie das für
symbolpolitik jetzt das brandenburger
tor schwarz gewaltigste symbolpolitik
nicht begehen sozusagen im bundestag
stimmt die fdp gegen die
laufzeitverlängerung der kernkraftwerke
und jetzt kommt kein da ja der
beleuchtung am brandenburger tor das ist
doch lächerlich und nehmen sie doch sie
können auch den funkturm nehmen sie
können den fernsehturm den bayern ist
doch ein wunderbares festival of lights
durchgängig 365 tage im jahr ja super
und es ist doch legitim diese frage zu
stellen ob sie irgendwo reduzieren oder
nicht aber versetzen sie sind bürger der
nicht für eigentlich wenig ertrag in
einen absoluten krisenmodus ich würde
denken wenn plötzlich mal unklar dunkel
ist was würde sehen lassen zwei oder
haben ängstigen wenn weniger beleuchtung
auf dem roten rathaus wäre als jetzt 1 8
das brandenburger tor war jetzt das
beispiel in einem lila aber wir können
ja mit augenmaß mal an diese frage hört
noch weniger als zehn toren
dagegen ich halte
in wenigen tagen klarheit über diese
frage haben wie viel das in der stadt
berlin ausmacht augsburg macht es doch
auch der name andere gemüse werden
ausgeschaltet
und sich mit diesen fragen
auseinandersetzen diese energiekonzepte
müsste ich ihnen sagen wir werden bei
ganze deutschen volk wirklich zeigen wie
lächerlich sich mittlerweile politik
machen fragen einer par als heimat
vielleicht ist ja einer in der runde der
dem vorschlag etwas abgewinnen kann
und wird sicherlich symbolisch kann man
das machen gelb ich glaube tatsächlich
auch dass die fdp sich mehr gedanken
darüber machen sollte wie sie es schafft
in der ampel die
das thema atomenergie aus programm zu
bringen und zu sagen dass das länger
läuft aber wird sind sie in der berliner
landespolitik
kann man machen schadet niemandem glaube
ich wirklich finde es ist ein film als
symbol
ich glaube schon dass wir irgendwann
darüber sprechen werden wo wir eventuell
verzichten müssen oder wo die menschen
sich einschränken müssen ich glaube
sicherlich
dass das passieren kann und dann kann
das ein symbol ich meine der staat hat
haben jetzt gerade eine berechnung
gesehen aus berlin das trifft sie jetzt
nicht weil sie in der opposition sind
natürlich millionen wurden verschleudert
indem man einfach die krone abrechnungen
von diesen teststationen nicht geprüft
hat millionen wurden verschleudern und
das war ein betrug mit ansage aber wir
als fdp raus ja absolut da bin ich ja
sehr dafür dass er macht eine
konstruktive opposition wunderbar
vielleicht bekommt ihnen die ampel nicht
so gut also das ist doch wahnsinn der
staat verschleudert geld mit ansage im
milliardenbereich und dann ist da noch
nichts gewonnen wenn er damals für fünf
minuten sagt so jetzt sehen wir mal ein
schlüssiger hand über und geh mal kurz
dunkel über den plan aber er ist ja sehr
mehrheit anderen telefonieren können
also nochmals geht ja nicht um dunkeln
es geht um die frage der
verhältnismäßigkeit darauf zu schauen
und ich halte dagegen wie und sage es
ist wesentlich mehr als sie jetzt mit
ihren zehntausenden
drei wochen aber es ist trotzdem der
scharia ich habe es trotzdem nicht gut
wenn sie nicht mal wissen was sie
bewirken dass sozusagen über das
deutsche fernsehen ins volk zu bringen
weil sie am ende damit etwas suggerieren
es ist ganz einfach ist doch ganz
einfach energie zu sparen ich sage ihnen
das bringt gar nichts licht bringt gar
nichts was sie machen müssen ist
wirklich dann ganz anders an die
energieeinsparung heranzugehen und da
reden wir dann wirklich über megawatt so
nicht über kilowattstunden
aber ihre aussage jetzt halte ich für
sehr relevant weil sie sie tun ja so als
dürfte man keine debattenbeiträge machen
müssen sie gern haben sich lächerlich
machen und da würde es gerne machen
darüber diskutieren das ist doch genau
das problem der vergangenen zeiten dass
wir denkt herr buß hatten über die frage
wie können wir an dinge heran gehen und
deshalb ist es in dem antrag machen sie
die großen zeigen gehört und ich habe
sich kleidung oder erdnüsse es geht
nicht um die frage wie können wir in
deutschland dem problem herr werden
sondern es ging darum wie können wir auf
der einen seite mehr schulden in der
stadt im land berlin vermeiden weil wir
genau wissen dass alles was wir schulden
finanziert tun und alles was wir an
paketen reingeben am ende auch zu lasten
der zukünftigen generation geht und noch
dazu im übertragenen sinne zum
inflationstreiber wird also können wir
doch auf der anderen seite bitte über
sinnvolle maßnahmen schauen und die
stadt etlichen ausgaben so in den griff
kriegen dass wir auf der anderen seite
auch
den extra aus berlin abstellen das würde
viel mehr bringen erfahren damit hatte
scheint natürlich recht jeder
debattenbeitrag darf natürlich
kritisiert werden
ja der welt sehen uns alle sehr ja es
gab ja mal ein kleines mädchen des
jungen frau wurde wir kennen sie noch
alle kreter thunberg easy und die hat
mal gesagt einwand youtube panic also
ich will dass ihre manik gerate das war
der modus wir sollten immer in panik
seien damit der klimawandel sich bewegen
lasse in den herzen handlungen der
bürger und der politiker ich bin
mittlerweile von panik geschüttet
geschüttelt wenn ich durch die deutschen
städte laufs ins berlin ist hamburg
stuttgart ähnliches leider auch mannheim
wo ich herkomme muss ich sagen man sieht
immer mehr müll man sieht immer mehr
verwahrlosung und ich glaube die
verwahrlosung und der müll gekommen von
der verwahrlosung im kopf von der
perspektivlosigkeit gewissermaßen vom
inneren zittern von der inneren
panischen stimmung die man den menschen
machte dass diese eben panisch reagieren
ungeordnet reagieren sich versuchen eine
müllproblematik zu entledigen ohne
müllgebühren zu zahlen und diese panik
mit einer busse von weiten teilen der
regierenden klasse geführt wenn herr
scholz zum beispiel sagt unser
bundeskanzler wir wollen uns unter hagen
der meint er wir wollen uns unterhaken
zum schafott zumindest sagte das mit
solcher leichenbittermiene und der habig
macht offenbar gar nicht mehr unter
einem albtraum szenario es hat ja
wirklich gesagt also wenn wir denn müll
aus dem kopf und die traurigkeit und
tristesse aus dem kopf und damit aus den
straßen bekommen wollen dann brauchen
wir ein wenig mit zuversicht und das
sage ich auch ihre richtung weniger
untergangs denken ja ich glaube da muss
ich jetzt mal urlaub scholz beiseite
treten
spd freut sich auch hier auch ein habe
ja wenn die sache nicht ist jetzt keine
untergangsstimmung ich weiß nicht in
welchem land sie leben in deutschland in
deutschland und der schweiz vielleicht
endlich so aus denn hier geht es
wirklich um alles und sie werden den
leuten nicht erklären
wenn das schon in manchen kommunen jetzt
diskutiert wird wir können noch den
alten menschen wärme hallen zur
verfügung stellen das finde ich wirklich
halten menschen sozusagen sich aus ihre
eigene wohnung leer will ja und
sozusagen wie zuwanderer behandelt im
eigenen lande dass kritiker die
verliebtheit in den untergang die nützt
uns nichts also wer sich in apokalypse
doch die war richtig schlimm wäre die
ernsthaft sich eine apokalyptische
szenarien für dich trägt der wirt ist
apokalypse auch erleben das glaube ich
nicht macht kann weg geben doppelt durch
die welt durch einen immer schmutziger
werden der welt übrigens und wenn wir
das botschaften ständig haben sparen
panik kommt wie kommt das denn bei
unternehmen bei kleinen selbstständigen
bei leuten die davon leben müssen dass
urlaubsgäste kommen alles wird
verschoben einnahmen werden reduziert
die leute haben angst am leben und wer
angst hat am leben und vor dem leben der
wird das leben nicht meistern eine herr
kessler die unternehmer haben im
augenblick eine verdreifachung ihrer
sehr weiser nicht ihre strompreise
kritisiere die kommen in panik ich habe
mir auch keiner der gerne panik
verbreitet aber wir müssen die wahrheit
sagen wir müssen sagen dass er im
augenblick der deutsche mittelstand fast
am ende ist der kann mit diesen preisen
nicht umgehen die stehen wirklich vor
dem ende und wenn das noch weitergeht
dann haben wir wirklich ein problem
deswegen glaube ich ich verstehe sich
schon richtig
panik wird auch keiner verbreiten wir
müssen sehen dass es ernst ist und das
müsst ihr aber schreiben durch
apokalypse als einer tür hier soll wenn
morgen die welt unterginge ich heute
noch ein apfelbäumchen pflanzen diesen
geist brauche doch viel eher als es ist
bald alles vorbei ist können jetzt noch
mal krachen lassen und natürlich angst
oder und eskapismus die zügel schießen
lassen
es ist immer eine frage der wahrnehmung
und da muss ich sagen als jemand der nun
in fünf monate in der ukraine war
dort sieht man jeden tag sehr viel
schlimmere dinge
als das was auf uns zukommen könnte aber
natürlich soll das nicht bedeuten dass
die menschen sich keine sorgen machen
müssen und ist es immer natürlich eine
frage der wahrnehmung wo man in dem
moment gerade ist und ich glaube dass
das natürlich
[Musik]
auch wenn ich mir die vergangenen fünf
monate anschaue also in den ersten
wochen hat die ganze welt auf die
ukraine geschaut da und jetzt
verschwindet das immer mehr aus den
nachrichten und natürlich das ist auch
ganz normal beschäftigen sich die
menschen mit den problemen die sie vor
ort und vor ihrer haustür erleben ich
glaube was gefährlich wäre wenn wir
sagen dass uns nur noch unsere eigenen
probleme interessieren und wir nicht
mehr auf die ukraine schon jetzt werden
gestern einen campingplatz besitzerin
hier sitzen nicht aus berlin das möchte
ich ihnen jetzt also gar nicht angreifen
sondern aus sachsen anhalt und gesagt
die menschen können ihre milch nicht
mehr zahlen und ziehen auf den
campingplatz als erstwohnsitz
ja die situation am wohnungsmarkt es
bitter und natürlicher berlin ein
extrembeispiel auch wir haben eine
leerstandsquote von 0,8 prozent man
findet hier kaum wohnraum also man kann
nicht mehr sich seiner lebenssituation
anpassen und selber umziehen geschweige
denn in diese stadt zu ziehen ist ein
riesen drama und das heißt natürlich
dass man
relativ schnell gerade auch bei
steigenden rohstoffpreisen jetzt noch in
einen größeren engpass reinkommt dem bei
bewältigen müssen mit mit mehr wohnraum
der zu schaffen ist absolut und wir
müssen auch gucken dass wir wieder
fairer mieten in unserem land bekommen
aber ich fand den appell gut zu sagen
wir müssen mehr german mut haben und
müssen nach nach vorne und dennoch ist
der status quo der gerade wenn wir über
die frage wohnungsmarkt reden dass wir
natürlich jetzt erstmal ein vielfaches
mehr an herausforderungen haben und wenn
dann und da bin ich bei den denk tabus
dies in krisenzeiten nicht geben darf
wenn dann kommunale
wohnungsbaugesellschaften sagen wir
können sechs euro 50 als miete durchaus
auch zukünftig stabil am markt halten
dafür müssen wir aber nicht nur wohnraum
preisgebunden im bezahlbaren segment
machen sondern müssen auch darüber
nachdenken gegebenenfalls
eigentumswohnung zu bauen
eine mischkalkulation haben und dass
dann politisch abgelehnt wird aus
ideologischen gründen ist so ein
bisschen wie diese harbeck diskussion um
die frage atomkraftwerke
laufzeitverlängerung dann haben wir ein
problem und dann wird der müll
irgendwann sinnbilder ist es und wir
brauchen einfach leute die sich für das
gemeinwesen zu engagieren weil sie eben
eine gute zukunft zutrauen und da haben
wir glaube ich zu wenig diese
in ihrer freizeit auch mal müll herr
kessler es gibt auch diese drei minuten
straßen cleaning so ein trend bei jungen
menschen also ich schaue schon das ist
in meinem umfeld weit es geht sauber ist
es den trend kenne ich jetzt noch nicht
aber will ich natürlich bleiben die
beiden beach klinik hat sich für sein
umfeld ein wenn etwas bedeutet wenn man
davon ausgeht dass es auch noch eine
gute zukunft hat und den leuten geht
irgendwann die lust an der zukunft das
zutrauen auch ins gemeinwesen komplett
abhanden mal lässt vermögen meisten
schleifen und das ist einfach ganz ganz
schlimm ich weiß im urlaub in
mitteldeutschland und dort haben die
leute auch schon so einen
niedergeschlagenen eindruck gemacht dann
sah ich ein ein schwimmbad das war
wunderbar wunderbar am zustand habe ich
gefragt warum ist er so toll sagt ja der
macht das was ihm wichtig ist weil es
ihr wichtig wer müsste es gar nicht
macht er macht nicht dienst nach
vorschrift dass es ihm wichtig dort noch
auch in der freizeit die blumen zu
schneiden und zu gießen er will dass es
schön aussieht und wenn andere kommen
das ist ja auch schön aussieht ich
fordere es nicht eine große schönheits
offensives darf auch durchaus hell
bleiben in berlin bei tag und bei nacht
aber ich glaube wir können aus krise
herauskommen danke schön wenn uns unser
land etwas bedeutet wenn wir eine
zukunft zutraut und gebückt und gedrückt
schaffen wir aber dass es auch an der
kommunikation unserer bundesregierung
muss man aber
ich rede nicht über den müll jetzt aber
ja da gerade die frage doch daran haben
wir leute zu wandern lassen die mit
zumüllen auch ein anderes zugang haben
das muss man noch aussehen anderen ist
doch so wenn wenn ich das sehe in meinem
umfeld das ist in meinem viertel ist das
alles politische sauber aber in anderen
vierteln ist es eben auch anders und bei
ihnen sind keine zugewanderten empfängt
ja ich bewohnern der elbe relativ gut
situiert da ist das nicht so aber wenn
sie auf der veddel sind haben sie andere
zu stellen das ist leider darf man aber
heute auch nicht mehr sagen das ist ja
schrecklich sie dürfen hierbei fehler
macht alles sagen aber ich sage es als
segen weil es jetzt einfach zu sagen
will ich sagen die bundesregierung ist
dafür schon das hat keiner gesagt
die massen zu tun ist sich sozusagen an
dem harmlosigkeit der deutschen ich gebe
ihnen recht was sie brauchen ist wir
brauchen aufbruchstimmung genau waren
auch verschwiegen bleiben und dazu
müssen wir erst mal ein paar habe auf
dem fuß stimmung hat dann mit
kommunikation zu tun richtig das ist
doch das problem und da bin ich bei olaf
scholz und sage wo ist olaf scholz es
gibt viele interviews aber nichts bleibt
hängen keine mut machenden setze
natürlich muss man waren und nahmen vor
dem was kommen könnte aber man muss auch
wieder ein bisschen optimismus und
anpackt mentalität er hat uns gesagt im
interview gesagt er will dafür einsetzen
dass die energiepreise explosion nicht
so groß ausfällt also es darf schon
etwas explodieren aber nicht so viel
sein ein tischfeuerwerk dass es geht um
tatkraft ja auch und ich kann eben ganz
spannendes stichwort dienst nach
vorschrift kißler und da hat ja ihr
parteivorsitzender christa länder
vorgeschlagen dass alle jetzt mal
ranklotzen und mehr überstunden machen
und los geht's deutschland sollen wieder
anschauen anschaffen nicht anschauen
[Gelächter]
ich glaube dass in unserem land richtig
viel an überstellung geleistet wird und
dass jeder der überstunden macht und
machen möchte das auch tut ich finde
aber den appell dahinter also die
haltung zu sagen jetzt packen wir
zusammen etwas an diese diese haltung zu
sein jedes dorf würden wir gehen wir
gehen nach vorne verschieben ich glaube
dass er das auch damit gemeint hat als
es um das zu übersetzen genau das was
portman eingefordert hat nicht so dröge
wie der wir jetzt gerade olaf scholz
beschrieben hat sondern eher mehr
christian lindner das habe ich so
verdienen das habe ich dir
bitte die fdp ist in die fdp verliebt so
bilden sie das jetzt den appell von
christian lender unterschreiben dass die
leute mehr überstunden machen sollen und
das war die frage
wir brauche ich von sollen reden
ich habe ihnen das ja gerade eingeordnet
wie ich es verstehe
die frage nicht beantworten weil ich
habe ist ja auch keine schwäche ich hab
ihnen beschrieben wie ich die frage
lesen kann jeder für sich selbst
beurteilen also bleiben wir doch bei den
positiven was für unser land aber die
leute sich das licht ausmachen die
können überstunden
letzte sind auch zu ihrer themen sind
was ist denn ihre konkrete forderung um
eine konkrete forderung dass wir eine
vernünftige politik machen die sich eben
nicht in untergangsszenarien erschöpft
sich nicht im moralischen appellen
erschöpft dass wir eine klare benennung
der ziele machen der wege die darin 1
schlagen sind und das gilt für ganz
deutschland eben am liebsten dazu dass
wir eine zielerfüllung überprüfung
machen dass wir schauen nach einer weile
das tat auch wilma bürokraten nein nein
habe sie
keine comedy und keine kommission steht
aber ich muss sagen ich schätze diese
sanktionen einen haben sie was erreicht
falls nicht müssen wir gegensteuern
haben diese maßnahmen was erreicht falls
nicht und generell ist der staat einfach
viel viel zu reich und die bürger sind
zu arm und das ist leider gottes auch
ein punkt wird in wir reden ich finde
das ist ein schönes schlussplädoyer für
die sendung und sie müssen morgen abend
unbedingt einschalten weil es die letzte
sendung vor der sommerpause also damit
der filmnacht entzug nicht zu groß wird
morgen abend definitiv noch einmal
einschalten dann gehen wir in
sommerpause herzlichen dank an meine
gäste das war sehr leidenschaftlich und
sehr lebendig und damit schönen abend
noch machen sie es gut
[Musik]